let's get to calls because the lines are
absolutely on fire I mean just shocking
what's going on with our phone lines
right now six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty is the number we'll
start with our first caller from the 801
area code caller from 801 what's your
name where you're calling from and
what's on your mind hey this is a
branson I'm from Salt Lake Utah I was
just a big fan of the show
thank you sir all thank you what's on
your mind today um yeah well I'm
studying economics University right now
if I understand right I think you said
you are also an economics student um
sorry that's where you graduate your
degree was in yes I have an
undergraduate degree in economics and my
MBA concentration was economics okay so
I was just wondering maybe normally in
economics we make arguments on
efficiency and I was just wondering how
you kind of justified your view on the
$15 an hour minimum wage well you're
gonna have to say more in terms of in
what way would a $15 minimum wage not be
efficient um well I was just thinking in
like I mean it's essentially a doubling
of the minimum wage so I mean in most
areas especially like I mean just for
example in rural Utah it just seems like
a big change yeah and so in what way
would it not be efficient well I mean if
you raise the cost of wages I guess the
argument would be that people would just
hire people for less hours fewer hours
right yeah I mean so in the places where
that's been explored it doesn't tend to
happen if we you know we can talk about
efficiency the thing is what what you
would expect to also see if you
increase the minimum wage to $15 and
this is an argument where if the counter
is well then why not raise it to 200 you
have to understand $200 an hour wouldn't
be an equilibrium wage if you raise the
minimum wage to $15 an hour number one
that would reduce poverty it would get
some people out of poverty and thus we
could argue that by having a smaller
population in poverty that adds to
economic efficiency because fewer people
require social programs which have
significant inefficiencies in terms of
means testing and bureaucracy if you
imagine someone who by virtue of getting
out of poverty just gets a bigger by
virtue of having a larger minimum wage
gets a higher minimum wage gets a bigger
paycheck from their employer it does not
change anything about the efficiency of
them receiving that wage they just get a
bigger check from their employer but all
of a sudden you reduce the workload for
somebody who previously might have been
involved in administering or approving
welfare benefits for that person for
example so people earning more money
through wages rather than through social
welfare programs I would argue is
significantly more efficient Wow okay
that makes sense that's would you also
kind of map here a Keynesian argument
here I'm sorry well what kind of
argument Keynesian like Keynesian
economics like redistribution I see no
listen I'm not sure I've studied
Keynesian economics I'm not the guy
who's gonna go around making the
Keynesian arguments so I think that
there's many shows that would ok Branson
appreciate the call thank you very much
always good to get economics questions
sometimes people get a little nervous
when they call that's okay happens
that's okay it happens to everybody